ينضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام نتعرف معك الياس على اخر
التطورات لكن ايضا فيما يتعلق بعمليه
الانزال الخامسه هذه التي تم تصويرها
واذاعتها يعني هل هنالك اي رسائل يمكن ان
تفهم من الحرص على تصويرها واذاعتها بهذا
الشكل نعم بالفعل وبامكان التاكيد على ذك
ان هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يقوم بها
الجيش الاسرائيلي بعمليه انزال جويه سواء
كان ذلك في منطقه خانيونس او في مناطق
اخرى في قطاع غزه وهو اشار في بيانه الى
انه قام بهذه الخطوه خمس مرات على الاقل
في عمر هذه الحرب الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بيانه اشار الى ان عمليه الانزال الجوي
اشتملت على سلاح وعتاد وماء ووقود وكذلك
غذاء للقوات الاسرائيليه في خان يون
وا بحجم
16 طن وهو قال بان الشحنات الشحنات
السابقه التي تم انزالها جوا اجملت على 60
طنا من هذا العتاد والمستلزمات اللازمه
للجيش الاسرائيلي لكن يطرح السؤال هنا هو
لماذا يجب على الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يقوم
بعمليه انزال جويه في منطقه جغرافيه ضيقه
نحن لا نتحدث عن حرب في ميادين واسعه
النطاق كما يجري مثلا في اوكرانيا حيث
المساحات الشازع وربما الحاجه لانزال جوي
للقوات نحن نتحدث عن منطقه ضيقه وممتده ما
بين غلاف غزه يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لكن واضح بان اضطرار الجيش
الاسرائيلي لعمليه انزال من هذا النوع هذا
يعني ان خطوط الامداد ما بين منطقه غلاف
غزه والمناطق التي توجد بها القوات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه ربما تكون غير امنه
وربما تكون معرضه لاطلاق النار من جانب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه و وبالتالي هي مناطق
غير مؤمنه لذلك يحتاج الجيش الاسرائيلي
الى عمليه الاز الانزال الجويه وربما هذا
يعني ان ايضا هذه القوات وكانها شبه
محاصره في تلك المناطق التي تنشط فيها
عسكريا وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي يكون
مضطرا للقيام بعمليات الانزال الجويه ايه
هذه وكما اشرنا هي المره الخامسه كما اشار
بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي
بهذا الخصوص وا اشتملت ايضا على على
العتاد العسكري وعلى الوقود وعلى المياه
وعلى الغذاء وما يلزم الجيش الاسرائيلي
ربما من معدات
ومستلزمات في اطار هذه العمليه المتواصله
والتي يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي بان الزخم
الاكبر لها هو يتم حقيقه في منطقه خانيونس
وفي المناطق الجنوبيه لكن اذا سالتني ما
الذي يجري هنا في شمال قطاع غزه حيث ان
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جلان كان اعلن
قبل يومين عن ان العمليات العسكريه الكبرى
قد انتهت بالامكان الغاء هذا التصريح كليا
حقيقه زين لان ما يجري في الساعات القليله
الماضيه في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
يشي ان العمليات العسكريه ما زالت في
ذروتها وما زالت على اشدها وهنالك حتى
اشتباكات تجري بالسلاح الرشاش الثقيل في
مناطق جباليا وغارات جويه تكاد لا تتوقف
حقيقه في الساعات الاخيره تحديدا تتركز
عند منطقه جباليا التي تعرضت الى اكثر من
غاره جويه عنيفه في الساعه ال الماضيه
وكذلك الضواحي الشماليه لمدينه غزه
بالاضافه الى منطقه الشجاعيه وبعض الاحياء
والاطراف الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه التي كانت
تعرضت ايضا في الساعه الاخيره لغارات جويه
عنيفه هذه الغارات الجويه تاتي بعد 24
ساعه من الدفعه الصاروخيه الهائله التي
اطلقتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه باتجاه مدينه
نيتي فوت في النقب الغربي والتي كانت تحمل
بحسب بلديه نتيفوت 50 صاروخا ونحن كنا
نقول بان منذ بدايه الحرب في السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي اسرائيل تعرضت من كل جبهات
القتال الى 11000 صاروخ ومن داخل قطاع غزه
ما يزيد على 9000 صاروخ لكن وقع هذه
الصواريخ بالامس على نيتي فوت كان قويا
جدا واثر حتى على تصريحات الوزراء
الاسرائيليين في الحكومه الاسرا اليه
الذين تساءلوا كيف يمكن للجيش الاسرائيلي
او للمستوى السياسي الذي يتخذ القرارات
العسكريه ان يوعز للجيش الاسرائيلي
بالانسحاب من قطاع غزه و وواضح بانه في
المكان الذي ينسحب منه الجيش الاسرائيلي
تعود حركه حماس لتملا هذا الفراغ عسكريا
وا مدنيا ايضا كما تشير بعض التقديرات
لذلك هنالك مطالبات من جانب اكثر من وزير
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبطبيعه الحال على
راسهم وزير الامن القومي اتمار بنفير الذي
يقول بان على الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يواصل
عمليته العسكريه بزخم وقوه اكبر على
اعتبار ان انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
قطاع غزه سوف يكبد الاسرائيليين خسائر على
الصعيد البشري ز شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام
من غلاف غز